Fox's new music competition show the
four and I gotta say Michelle this looks
good it looks really good I can't wait
for this nail list and I know what some
of you out there may be thinking there's
already the voice there's already
American Idol can it even compare well I
will give you four reasons it's a TV
game changer I was really excited
because it's brand new and it's not what
you've seen before
number one the premise is original I
want to see a challenge in this
competition the top singers are already
chosen but it's up to them to stay in
the Final Four what you're going to get
is unpredictability are you one of these
seats yes sir it's the biggest show ever
the second reason this show is different
the winner wins the panel has career
coaches you get us the four of us to
help you and guarantee you that we will
make you a global superstar know what my
focus is gonna be on taking this
undiscovered talent and nurturing them
no the show runs only six weeks so you
better tune in early starting tonight on
Fox
another reason to watch the judges
chemistry is real well you know we've
known each other for so many years we're
all friends I'm outtie we're like real
brothers you know we have dinner
together we go to each other's houses
for years and finally the fourth reason
this thing off is gonna rock it has the
Fergie back the Welcome committee and
the hostess with the mostess
I love giving somebody new who's hungry
and who wants it a chance to get up on
that stage and become that star
you